[Music]
ann is with us in grand rapids michigan
hi ann how are you
hi dave god bless you
you too
how can we help you
thank you so much um i'm making
1500 a month on social security
and i make another 500 a month
substitute teaching
um and
i'm paying my sister 500 a month
to pay her back the 20 000 ior
and that will take me three years but in
the meantime
i'm not tithing at all and i'm and i
don't quite know what to do about that
how old are you
72 okay all right
well i think it's always good when we're
talking about tithing to uh pull back
from the details of the situation
and just um
unpack okay yes those of us that are
christians uh the vast majority of us
believe that the bible says
to tithe to give a tenth of our income
to our local church that's the
definition of the word from an
evangelical christian standpoint and
that's what you're calling about so
let's pan back from that then and say
okay what what is god doing
with this tithe thing
why is he teaching us to tithe and then
what are some of the details around it
number one um
he is not teaching us to tithe because
he needs money he's god he doesn't need
money
okay
number two he's not teaching us to tithe
because the local church needs our
support although that is one of the
byproducts of the tithe
but that's not that's not why scripture
teaches us to tithe
your heavenly father who is absolutely
crazy about you
and he loves you little girl
teaches you to give
because it's good for you
it changes you
and that's the reason generosity always
makes all of us smile
generosity always makes our eyes leak
right
and so this is not a rule to be kept by
an angry father
this is a loving
father that says hey little girl
best way to live your life is to be
generous and here's a good rule of thumb
a tenth of your income now if we want to
get technical about the income let's get
technical about it
i'll give you an opinion but i want you
to live in a lot of grace around this
god does not love tithers more than
non-tithers
you don't get brownie points with god
for tithing
that's not why you do it the reason you
do it is it's good for you to learn what
it does to your heart when you're
generous
and that's why giving is good for
everyone that's jesus says better to
give than receive and the reason is what
happens inside of you not because you're
more noble or more altruistic or you're
a better person because you're a giver
rather than a taker you know it has
everything to do with your heart so now
that we've established that there's a
lot of grace around the subject then the
technicality is the the best indicator
we have is in deuteronomy it says to
tithe on your net
increase
now that would be if you're are earning
a wage
which you said you're earning 500
okay right right
social security we could argue is not
earning
it you paid into it
it's a horrible retirement plan
that you paid way more into it than
you'll ever get out
right and so i'm not sure
i consider that income you can if you
want because if you want to be a bigger
giver it's never a bad thing
but in my mind with what you described
what you owe your sister has nothing to
do with the equation mathematically i
would be tithing on the 500 worth of
income
and then i would pray and ask god if you
think you're supposed to tithe on the
other social security income
so 50 bucks
and i think you can probably pull that
off even in your really really tight
budget yeah absolutely i mean 50 bucks
from your income and i don't know your
your expenses and when it comes down to
the budget but i would take a good look
at the budget and see if we can
fine-tune some things because clearly
giving is something that you're
passionate about it's something that you
want to do and i love your heart and
faithfulness around this and so i think
you look at the budget and go i know we
i don't have a lot coming in but what
are some areas i can shave to make this
50 happen so that i can be generous yeah
i don't think you're 50 off even in your
tight budget one way or the other
um but again you you um you continue to
pray about this and i want you to have a
peace about it i want you to walk i want
everyone in your generosity to walk in
grace
but the principle is there
those that win with money are generous
very few people do we find in all of our
data points that are very good with
money unless they're generous that's the
little secret that nobody talks about
much
or enough
this is the ramsay show